je réponds course et c'est un vrai film
hanté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas afin jeu je suis pas
lecteurs de charlie hebdo d'aujourd'hui
mais je suis ravi qu'ils existent et qui
qui continue quoi
blackrock est éteint et nationales les
plus puissantes au monde et ils sont
d'énormes lobbyistes et si on a d'une
sorte de volonté tellement farouche de
manuel macron de faire passer cette loi
sur les retraites est d'amener la
privatisation des retraites d'amener les
retraites versées ces grosses sociétés
financières américaines qui veulent
prendre l'argent des épargnants des
retraités pour les placer en bourse
on doit essentiellement à blackrock et à
son pdg larry fink comme la croix qui
présente partout ici ils sont également
actionnaires des big pharmas il en
particulier de jill aide c'est comme de
l'eau dans du sable ils vont unis vont
ils vont aller partout où il ya de
l'argent à se faire et il ya énormément
d'argent à se faire dans les dents les
dans les labos et dont les vaccins
blackrock son moteur c'est le fric c'est
la cupidité la rapacité la santé ou la
green economy ils en ont rien à
ils vont tenir des discours publics
c'est assez généreux de ce côté là mais
ce qui compte pour eux c'est de nous
faire les poches
[Musique]
bien sûr commandes enquête sur
clearstream valait le coup puisque je
crois que c'est jean luc mélenchon au
parlement européen il a dit que le
stream c'est la mère de toutes les
enquêtes
c'est à dire que c'est la première fois
que désigne cider don d'une
multinationale sortait des listings
financiers et l'anc est à au moins
éclairés sur le fonctionnement opaque de
la finance internationale
après effectivement le fait qu'ils aient
multiplié les procédures contre moi et
qui ont duré dix années quand même il a
eu 63 plaintes
donc ça a été un long combat mais
aujourd'hui il faut à 2-2 bénéfices le
premier c'est qu'il ya une jurisprudence
qui existent et qui protège les
journalistes il va ça mon combat
judiciaire que j'ai fini par gagner
contre clearstream puisque mon enquête a
été déclarée par la cour de cassation
sérieuse de bonne foi et servant
l'intérêt général et le deuxième c'est
que j'ai mis l'éclairage sur le
fonctionnement de la planète financière
et j'ai expliqué quelque chose que
personne encore n'avait n'avait explorer
qui sont les chambres de compensation
internationale c'est à dire la manière
dont l'argent circule véhicule et qu'il
est il existe derrière les bancs des
banquiers surpuissant des notaires qui
qui qui archivent toutes les données
financières et on peut retrouver comme
ça la trace de n'importe quelle
transaction grâce à l'informatique
mais pour l'instant ni les juges ni les
enquêteurs financier de sang ne s'en
serve mais mon enquête marque une sorte
de repère pour tous ces gens là et elle
m'a causé beaucoup de soucis mais en
même temps je suis très fier de l'avoir
mené et de l'avoir mené jusque là
il n'existe pas véritablement d'outils
de webtélé de sites d'information qui
soit un service public c'est à dire
ouverts à tous on aspire à être le média
des médias indépendants on aspire à
peser dans le jeu donc on va faire des
lives refaire des émissions politiques
j'ai refermé édito on va faire de la
culture des émissions littéraires etc
tout ça on va le construire
la télé va démarrer début mars on va
lancer des programmes en février et la
campagne commence cette semaine
j'espère que le public sera au rendez
vous et qu'on va casser la baraque avec
blast
[Musique]